you better just you better not Bank your
deal on Washington fixing your life ever
even in a crisis that's right I mean
let's just say you got $40,000 in
student loan debt and they send you
you're married so they send you a 1200
otter check each so you got $2,400 and
they forgive ten thousand dollars of
your student loan debt okay and now I
got thirty thousand in student loan
death and and you do you have a job okay
I don't know you may know if you have a
job and you were making $60,000 or
eighty thousand dollars before you still
do right
so you haven't you have a $12,000 swing
in your entire situation and is that
helpful yes send me $12,000 I'll take it
but it doesn't fix your life that's
right it's it's a it's a it's a five or
a ten percent move in your net worth and
you've still got to deal with the other
95% of crap that's in your life and so
that's what I mean when I say it's more
psychology and politics than it is
arithmetic uh-huh uh-huh and so it's a
you know if a thousand dollars changes
your life by definition you didn't have
much of a life by definition that's not
being snobby no no no that's just saying
you really were pretty freakin broke
right I mean like poverty level already
yeah you already had bigger problems
than the coronavirus if a thousand
dollars changes your life and so that's
what I mean it's to me it's just BS yeah
its peeing on a forest fire it really is
this over there and I know for the
people that are out there if they've
just raised the lampshade for you or the
shade on the window and you're seeing it
clear that's a good thing what happens
at your house is more important than
what happens in the white house that's
right except if the white house will
tell us all we can go back to work so
that you can pay the bills at your house
I mean that that's a big deal right
there it is I'm not trying to kill your
grandmother don't don't get mad at me
I'm not trying to be socially
responsible and I know you want to
flatten the curve send me the hash tag I
mean I get all that I understand all
that I'm not trying to kill the soul but
the the cure has become much more of a
then the virus and it's really hurting
people's lives because we deal with
these people that are hurting and when
only you guys in you're hurting and we
don't want anybody sick no and if you
say that about me then you're just being
irrational and you're just being
fear-based and mean okay that's just not
true but but it's just a matter I have
you know I'm an honest intellectual
disagreement with you on which is worse
the cure or the virus and and I've got
I've got responsibility to a thousand
people here that heat out of this place
and we don't have a print money printer
at Ramsey solutions or on a machine down
here we can just print up money pay all
these people so we're like any other
business that's a thousand families that
get paid here and lots of businesses are
facing the exact same thing you know
they're and they're all at home right
now working from home because that's
what the governor and the mayor and the
president asked us to do and we did that
last week and you know they're all
working from home and it's not good
y'all it's not good so anyway that's
what we're facing and we're gonna walk
through this together so I think that's
what you look at here is on the stimulus
thing is does the stimulus really does
it really stimulate you art Laffer
proposed one that was interesting which
was forgiving it was more substantial
than this in actual math it was
forgiving the payroll tax till the end
the year zero payroll tax which would
give every worker a seven and a half
percent pay raise and every employer a
seven half percent seven seven six five
on every employee that they pay and so
it would stabilize the businesses that
create the jobs you know people eat with
yes the world and it would help the
people eat because they would
immediately get the equivalent of a
seven percent pay raise just through the
end of the year that that was an
interesting one to think about but
that's a whole lot more money oh then
but I was taller yeah oh absolutely it's
a whole lot more money or even it's
probably more than $12,000 per person
but you talk about something that would
impact not only a team member but also
the business in a loud thing you know
and it's not of course the the the
people on the left are gonna be all your
supporting businesses they understand
businesses are where you eat from this
is where you get your money for your
toilet paper because you catch the check
because you worked there yeah and we
want to make sure that you are still
able to cash your check to buy your
toilet paper and if you don't have a
check to buy your toilet paper things
get messy and so that that's what we're
dealing with here and it's it's the
problem it's just a problem and so it's
not you know this probe businesses means
that you're Pro people yeah and you're
Pro people you have to say I want those
precious low people to have a job that's
right
no you're those people that believe
those people that work at restaurants
that don't work at restaurants right now
they used to work at restaurants and
they used to work at a hotel they would
like for that business to be stimulated
yeah we'll be able to bring them to
bring them back who are you helping are
you helping the Marriott if you give the
Marriott money if it causes all the
people that used to work there to be
able to come back no you're helping the
people used to work there so you're
helping and so I don't like trickle-down
economics I know you don't like logic I
get it I understand but that's how this
stuff works boys and girls out here in
the real world where the rest of us live
other than Washington to the freaking DC
or in the mind of some liberal okay and
so I'm sorry y'all this is just what's
really going on you can be mad at me if
you won't be mad at me on our own mad at
me about something anyway but deal with
it but you know we're here to help
real human owners get their lives
straightened out that's a big deal